à pâques on entend plusieurs formes
cloche mais pourquoi a t'on du mal à
reconnaître notre propre voie quand elle
est produite par un enregistrement
quand il sort d'un haut parleur le sont
dans notre voie se propage dans l'air
les molécules qui composent l'air sont
mis en mouvement par la vibration de
haut parleurs elle se compriment et se
détendent la vibration se diffuse de
proche en proche jusqu'à nos tympans qui
vibre à leur tour ce qui gênait raciale
qui est transmis au cerveau quand nous
parlons leçon que nous produisons ne se
déplace pas uniquement dans l'air il se
propage également dans nos tissus les
eaux de la boîte crânienne en
particulier le signal qui arrive à notre
cerveau est donc légèrement différent un
peu plus grave que le son de cette
capsule 2d confiné qui arrive à vos
oreilles si vous avez aimé cette capsule
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleus
sachez que vous pouvez également voir ou
revoir ses vidéos en cliquant sur le
côté en haut ou en bas
et pour être sûr de ne louper aucune
bien abonnez vous et activer la cloche
allez à bientôt et n'oubliez pas nous
sommes confinés
mais on reste en lien